first and foremost let me turn you
around and explain this red here talk
about it
that's coming next that's coming next
all the way high just I'm just having
I guess re-enjoying fashion and playing
with color I'm in a very colorful mood
it I feel like you are you've hit a
phase of your life where you're having
fun again you're like energized and I
see all these artists that are newer
artists and oh and and establishers that
are flocking to you now that want to be
a part and do things what is that like
I feel like I'm going through this
reunion with a lot of artists that were
kids when my music first came out I mean
there were five six seven years old and
now they're they're all grown up and
they're able to speak for themselves and
tell me how much you know my music meant
to them at the time and
so I kind of feel like I'm you know
revisiting
that wave of connection from I guess I
would call it more of a generation
Bridge yeah yeah all right tell me about
the hat and the polka dots and and the
bell bottoms and oh gotta have some
great bell bottoms uh I'm just enjoying
and that's part of the reason why the
red hair because you know I thought I'm
going to be wearing black and white so I
wanted to pop on the top
um this is a this is a British designers
named Harris Reed he's just a really fun
um designer plays with texture and shape
and silhouette so you did a really cool
surprise on the Kelly Clarkson show to
the Boykin sisters and they were so
excited to see you but what does that
mean that you see people not only across
genres but across different races that
how you have transcended so many people
places and things oh gosh I wish uh I
wish I'd love to just see
more of us joining together to share our
cultures and our music and influence
each other and Inspire each other we
need more of it so
um but even just on another note of
sheer Talent these girls they've got
this gorgeous Blends and they're so
talented I really am rooting for them I
really want to see them get far they
should you're presenting tonight except
what is that like you come here you make
a splash on the carpet you get to
present have you had a great Grammy week
I'm here to represent country music I
mean I'm here to represent fashion you
know I'm um enjoying being the queen of
me which is my new album but I'm here to
um present the country album of the year
so I'm excited about that it's a great
lineup and I'm also just excited about
bumping into some friends here and other
artists it's there's so much amazing
talent this time here is a fan really
totally as a fan I can't wait to get my
hugs in I love the red here I love the
outfit I love you and everything you do
because I mean you like I said you've
inspired so many people and it means the
world to them thank you thank you very
much
[Music]
foreign